here with more arizona attorney general
mark bernovich he's now running for
senate against mark kelly the democratic
incumbent
fox news contributor newt gingrich i'll
start with you mr attorney general
because you did something quite
interesting
and the supreme court recently upheld
that arizona's voting rules
that restrict ballot harvesting and the
submission of provisional ballots
outside of uh one's home precinct this
was a big
win and for the court to finally take it
up to me it was a little too little
too late but a big win a tip of the hat
to you sir
thank you thank you sean for having me
on and i think the importance of that
case is it was a six to three decision
and i
argued it is that the supreme court
recognizes that election integrity
measures
common sense measures are okay they're
consistent with the constitution
and the constitution recognizes that
states can set
time place and manner statutes regarding
how
elections are conducted that's what the
constitution provides for
and the reality is as you pointed out in
your beginning
is that the left is so hypocritical we
literally just argued another case last
week
where the democrats challenged our laws
on ballot curing basically if you don't
sign your ballot you have to do so by
election day
there are states like new york
connecticut and the northeast that don't
allow any curing at all
is the dnc suing them is biden calling
them out
no because his rhetoric is basically
about dividing this country
and i think we all agree that common
sense election integrity measures
are good not only for arizona but for
america okay
mr speaker they're calling this the
worst challenge to our democracy since
the civil war
you're a historian i think you'll take
issue with that
then they're insulting people that live
in rural communities they're saying it's
an assault on democracy an assault on
on liberty and they're calling it jim
crow
i don't know great irony when i compared
your home state of georgia
and their law their voting law
with delaware it is far more restrictive
in delaware
and far more accessible in your state of
georgia
well when you're certainly technically
correct
but of course that's not what this is
about this isn't about
facts this is about a narrative and and
i'm going to
surprise you in two counts first of all
i don't know how many people picked up
on this
but we ought to start talking about vice
president kinko harris
kinkos went out of business 13 years ago
i mean this is a woman totally out of
touch with reality
a lot of people worry about president
biden and his cognitive abilities
we want to watch her for a week she
literally
cited kinko's kinkos has not been in
existence for 13 years
and i know that's a tricky thing if
you're from california
but still i think it tells you much a
lot about who they are
they don't know anything they're not in
touch with reality
they make it up as they go along but i'm
going to shock you
i agree with the president this is the
greatest
threat to the survival of freedom since
the civil war
they are determined to use the power of
the federal government
they're determined to destroy the
american military
by bringing wokeness in they're
determined to weaken the police
while strengthening criminals they're
determined to use the justice department
they're determined to side with
oligarchs in censoring americans
i believe this is the greatest threat
domestic threat
not counting the soviet union or nazi
germany
the greatest domestic threat the united
states has faced to freedom
since the civil war and the threat is
entirely
in the democratic party and it is a
mortal threat
and if they get their way if they can
pass the corrupt politicians act
you will see them steal everything they
need to steal
it is amazing the the rhetoric that
they're uh
using jim crow 2.0 the worst since the
civil war
do you think they're successful we have
about 30 seconds each mr attorney
general's story with you
no i think that it's dangerous for the
president united states to use that kind
of rhetoric
he ran as someone who said he was going
to be middle of the road and instead
he's putting this country on the highway
to hell
as the speaker just indicated they are
shredding the constitution
and we need to stand up now because who
knows when our liberties
will be uh be able to be saved again the
the polls show mr speaker you've read a
lot of polls in
in your many years that this is not this
is an 80 20 issue here
this is not even close people want these
simple integrity measures put in place
and we need them
but but here's the problem you've got
freedom in cuba is probably an 80 20
issue
that doesn't mean the cuban government
won't shoot enough people to slow it
down
freedom in venezuela is probably a 90 10
issue
the fact is these people the bidens
the harrises the schumers the pelosis
they're corrupting the military they're
corrupting the entire system
and they will do whatever they have to
to try to dominate us
and to dominate all of the american
people and impose their radical values
this is the greatest threat to the
united states since the civil war
that's scary mr speaker especially with
your knowledge of history thank you it
is
mr attorney general good luck in your
senate race we're following that very
closely against mark kelly out in
arizona
important race for the country hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else